in the lobby of Ramsey solutions
Christie is with us hi Christie welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave thank
you so much I'm so excited to be here
well we're honored to have you and who's
the pretty young lady with you this is
Julia she's my daughter
how old is Julia she's 6 and a half and
the house important the half is very
important
that's very good cool so where do you
live oh we're from Denver Colorado
Wow I made the trip all the way to
Nashville to do a debt free scream
that's the only reason we came flew in
this morning Wow we're honored to have
you well thank you for being here how
much have you paid off a little over
16,000 dollars good for you and how long
did that take you about five and a half
months good I love it
love it very cool making what kind of
money around 50,000 all right cool so
what kind of debt was this you know it
was a I almost wish I could say it was
student loan debt it was worse and
stupider it was um it was personal loans
payday loans cash advances from my bank
I got so many overdraft things I thought
they were love notes coming to me in the
mail sounds like sounds like you were
kind of living in desperation it really
was we were behind on the four walls we
were behind on electricity and water and
not because I didn't make enough money
because I didn't tell my money where to
go Wow so um yeah so that's where I'm
and I had some personal loans to people
wouldn't knoe car loan no credit card no
Sallie Mae just um just a lot of
desperation of desperation loans yeah a
lot of those all representatives out of
control yeah totally so um how did you
get there
did you hadn't always been that way how
did you reach that point of desperation
well I kind of had been there but um I
went through a separation and a divorce
and um but you we weren't good with
money together and we weren't good with
money apart it was not really you know
him or me with money exactly it's
terrible because getting your nails done
it's more important than paying your
life bill yeah I mean you know okay yeah
so I what happened five and half months
ago well I literally I woke up on a
Saturday morning and I'm an associate
pastor at a church and so you're kind of
the the name you know in Christian
finance and I whoa
up literally on a Saturday morning in
September and I thought I am the only
person in charge of my money like it was
right freshly after the divorce was
final and I was like uh-huh it was kind
of a heavy feeling and kind of a freeing
feeling at the same time and I just
thought I gotta find something and so
you're the name so I looked it up and I
started listen to your podcast Oh three
hours a day and it seemed a little maybe
excessive but um it is you know I'm a
kind of excessive person you needed you
needed something excessive right then
well the truth is that you know um I
needed my mind renewed in that area yeah
so I had my my my needed renewed when it
came to money I was at either as a giver
I just was terrible with everything else
and I'm so that's what I started doing I
started listening to it every day every
day every day
and the plan I tell people that um the
plan the baby steps Dave Ramsey plan
whatever you want to call it isn't like
a light at the end of the tunnel it's a
light at the end of the tunnel with maps
and bridges and I just not only could I
see like okay yeah on the sweet
by-and-by I had a map how to get there
and bridges that taught me how to cross
things and it just
we went bananas and we we Julia and I we
went crazy
we sold tons of stuff and I got rid of
them I I got rid of like my hairdresser
which was drastic the first time I went
you sell your hairdresser let me tell
you how much she cost me a lot she's
really caused me a lot and so I went
from pan close to $200 a month for hair
the first time I pulled into a beauty
school I text my sister and to my
friends y'all need to be an intercession
ha ha ha ha 45 minutes and so I went
from like a 200 dollar hair bill to like
a $35 hair bill and I'm and and I didn't
look terrible so we did ok we just got
rid of cable we got rid of Internet we
got rid of them just every dumb I sold
every purse that I owned I sold clothes
I sold
furniture and we just slamma-jamma that
thing we said I'll pass how are my
Christmas bonus everything we just threw
it on there so you were doing the
written plan the written budget the
budget changed everything because it
really wasn't an income problem no I I
have a okay I'm a good income
it was just somewhere after you start
doing the budget two three four even
five months in as a pastor mm-hmm did
you have a sense that there had been a
spiritual turn I can't even describe it
I can't describe it was so spiritual
it's such a part of my as a matter of
fact I've had the opportunity now to UM
to minister to a lot of single parents
on the like the fact that I know exactly
when her college fund is going to start
and I know when my retirement fund is
going to start I know when we're going
to finish our emergency our bigger
emergency founder step 3
those are that would be like speaking
Chinese to me about nine ten months ago
and so for me it would just became it's
kind of like when you get a plan where
there is no plan people perish
I was perishing in the area of finances
but as soon as we wrote the plan and we
made it plain it's like God just
breathes his breath on it and stuff just
started just going like that I had
$3,500 of that debt forgiven because
somebody found out I was on this plan
and had seen how much we had done they
just said you know what we're gonna
bless you and your family that 3500 you
owe us you don't know what's anymore so
you felt your father smiling it oh my
goodness yes
yeah yeah I I experienced that that's
why I was asking and you know once you
turn and start walking away from stupid
and you leave stupid in the rearview
mirror and you start walking in the
right direction I think we call that
repentance yes you know you turn that's
what it means and so we're turning 180
and we're heading the other direction
you haven't made a lot of progress yet
but just the intense change of direction
cause things to start to fall in place
and bad things to start to fall away it
was it was trippy I still remember it
was 30 years I still remember it's don't
ever that feeling yes and and and you
know when we talk about we Christians
talk about stewardship it sounds so you
know biblical or so King James or
whatever but really that's what it is
it's about getting control and and then
God looking down going but there's a
faithful one I can I can trust this one
it I'd always been at either but I just
didn't have it all like there's you know
that there's the times that you want to
do something extra or you want to bless
somebody else but because of your
disaster you can't and now we can and
actually that's one thing when we were
um we're really close to being debt-free
um we were riding in the car and I said
well jewels were real close to being
debt-free so what should we do to
celebrate and she said um well I want to
go eat at Casa Bonita uh-huh and if
you're um from Denver that's kind of
funny but um because we had eaten we
didn't do rice and beans we did at ramen
noodles and turkey sandwiches and then
she said I said well we need to do
something to be generous and so what's
something we could do because we do and
we during the plan I got um smart money
smart kids and so we have the give save
and spend we have she's got her job list
she knows how much earning potential she
has per week you know and so I said
what's something we should do to be
really generous to celebrate and she
thought for a few minutes and she has a
friend who at the time didn't have a bed
and she said well I'd like to get my
friend a bed and as a mom I mean I just
wanted to cry yeah
and I'm now giving is an option for her
but what how she spends her saving her
spend is we have a conversation so I
said it was gonna take every dollar in
your save and your spend mm-hm so you
you need to think about this it's this
what you wouldn't do and so she thought
about it for a little bit and she said
um for my friend it's worth it I like
her so I am we went together and we got
a bed mattress she picked out the
bedding and as a celebration for
becoming debt-free we um we got to bless
somebody with a bed there you go Anna
was a really big deal that's cool yes so
great story pastor I love it
how's it feel now oh my gosh it's
awesome it's just amazing because it's
just such a great feeling and what's so
exciting is being able to give other
people hope and to be able to tell them
you know that God can turn it around for
them but they have to make some effort
amen all right Christy and Julia from
Denver 16
and dollars paid off in five and a half
months making 50 a year count it down
let's hear a debt for each scream three
two one we did it we robbed it
I love it
awesome that's great that's fabulous
this is the Dave Ramsey show